too
tni
みなさんこんにちは
私はメイクアップアーティストという仕事をしています
雑誌や広告に登場するモデルさんのメイクアップを手がけたりしています
メイクアップの傍ら鹿児島をテーマにしたイベントの主催などいろいろな活動をしてい
ます
いろいろな活動をしすぎて
平野さんは何をしている人ケーっと良く聞かれるので
今日は15年続けてきた本業のメイクアップについて少しお話しします
18歳東京から鹿児島から東京へ
25歳東京からニューヨークっ
28歳帰国
今は鹿児島と東京を行き来する生活をしています
今日は皆さんに3つのことをお伝えします
メイクアップは人を美しくするだけでなくいろいろな幅や
可能性があります
今から少し
私のメイクアップの仕事を紹介します
これはニューヨークでの雑誌の撮影風景です
これはニューヨークでのファッション撮影
ドレスブランドクオン大樹とのファッション撮影
これは鹿児島出身で東京で活躍中のモデル
オバマなチケさんとの撮影です
20代私はこんな仕事をしてきました
そして今私の仕事の軸は大きく変わりつつあります
これから皆さんにメイクアップの意味や価値を考えていただくためにちょっとした場
お見せします
実はこの会場の中に私がメイクアップをした
おばあちゃんが隠れています
皆さん周りを見渡してみてください
では読んでみますねー
うレーサー
はいぶれーさんです
何歳でしょう
50代
60代
70台
はい
では
ウェーブをとっていきます
はいっ
レーサーしん
32たいです
ありがとうございません
メイクアップのこれがもう一つの側面です
そして他にもこんなメイクの楽しみ方があります
これは
芋焼酎が美味しいすぎて酔っぱらってしまったというストーリーで
女子8人で東京都苗を徘徊した時の写真です
メイクって
何のためにあると思いますか
自分を良く見せるため
綺麗になるためコンプレックスを隠すため
ここで少し私の話をします
私も昔コンプレックスがたくさんありました
外見で言うと鼻がでかい
背が低い
顔が濃ゆい
鹿児島から東京へ出た私は田舎っぺに見られたくない
そんな私を隠すために
こんな感じで
金髪にしたり
顔にピアスをしたりドレッドヘアーにしたり
メイクをたくさんを重ねていました
将来のこともあまり考えずよくわからなくて
私は
自分にもどかしさを感じていました
そして海外に行くことを決心したんです
そしてたどり着いたニューヨーク
ニューヨークで様々な国籍の友達や
色々な経験を通して
一人の一人の個性が大切にされる環境に触れました
そこで私を縛っていた固定概念に気がついたんです
例えばメイクは筆でしないといけないという思い込み
メイクは毎日しないといけないという思い込み
ニューヨークはそんな固定的な考え方を大きく変える自由な日の価値観があったんです
そして出会った後強化後島
鹿児島は本物の美しい素材にあふれた素晴らしい町だったんです
鹿児島は美しい
鹿児島の人も美しい
私は鹿児島の美しい素材を使ってもっともっと世界中の人を美しくしたいそう思うよう
になりました
ここで
私がお伝えしたい
あなたを美しくする3つのルールです
一つ目
こうあるべき
という価値観に縛られないこと
私はこうあるべきに縛られていました
若い頃肌が荒れていた私は当然のように毎日洗顔をしてしっかり保湿をして
皮膚科にも行きましたがなかなか肌は良くなりません
そこでちょっと考え方を変えて
洗顔をやめてスキンケアを見直してみました
すると自分の肌がよみがえってきたんです
今まで常識だと思っていたことが常識でないこともあるということ
固定概念に縛られていると
本当に見たいものが見えなくなるかもしれません
なので固定剤年はしてて
新しいものの見方を発見できればと思います
二つ目
シンプルにしてみること
シンプルが一番よ
母がいつも言ってました
私が尊敬する大人の女性はシンプルな方が多いです
スキンケアもメイクアップも生活も
やりすぎないやらなさすぎない
ちょうどいいあんばいば一番です
フルメイクをいつもしている人は大
一つポイントメイクを外してみる
メイクをしない人は一つポイントメイクを足してみる
そうすることで今まで気づかなかった自分の美しさに気づくかもしれません
3つ目は続けること
これは直接美しさに関係ないかもしれませんが私は続けることを大切にしています
小さなことでも
コツコツ
大きくなくても続ける
自分が興味のあることは
時間をかけてでも続けてみる
私の尊敬する先生が言っていた言葉です
焦らず慌てず諦めず
そして最後に私は鹿児島を世界一美人の多い街にする計画
鹿児島美人計画
という活動をしています
そのロゴを皆さんに見ていただきます
みなさん何かに見えますか
これは鹿児島県の海に浮かぶ美しい女性の横顔です
首には島々という宝石のネックレスをまとっています
鹿児島県の地図という固定概念に縛られているとこの美しい女性を発見することはでき
ません
あなたが持っている
宝石を輝かせるのもあなた次第です
それぞれの持っている宝石が世界中でキラキラ輝くことを願って私は活動を続けていき
たいとおもいます
ありがとうございましたあ